it's milk shiner movement out of sight
from the LA
it's a myth shine
we wanted fresh we wanted can you tell
me you why you came out here today just
to support the raw milk movement we've
been drinking raw milk for about six
years and I want easy access to it I
want to be doing it over the table not
under the table I came out here today to
make a point with a lot of my friends
out here that it's a simply ludicrous
that some folks think they have the
right to dictate what you can and can't
put in your body I'm a big advocate of
the idea of self-ownership and therefore
self-government and that people can
ingest whatever substances they want as
long as about negatively impacting the
rights of others I came out here today
to support voluntary exchange think it's
natural human interaction and its best
and it should be free people hire me to
help them lose weight and get healthy so
when I use raw milk with my clients they
get healthy and they lose weight I think
that we should be able to eat and drink
the foods of our choice and get them
from the sources that we want to have
you seen any cops out today um no they I
haven't even seen any walk by or drive
by I mean last year we had 15
surrounding us within the first five
minutes and here nobody showed up I
think they learned their lesson do you
think that anybody should be able to
sell anything to anybody I mean I
wouldn't say that's the case I think the
government does have some you know
authority in jurisdiction they mean you
can't just sell poison to people if
they're not harming anybody or anyone's
property I don't see I don't see a
problem with that as long as you're not
out hurting an injured third party um
the the argument for why something
shouldn't take place or something
shouldn't happen you know really is you
know comes down to the old victimless
crimes aren't legitimate crimes that the
FDA is just protecting the monopoly the
corporate monopolies on the dairy
industry you also want to say if you
consume lemonade you must first get my
permission and that just shows upon them
some higher authority and again what I
would say is that that doesn't exist the
claim authorities is arbitrary just
because someone who happens to work at a
certain occupation or where a certain
costume that doesn't give them any more
right so you know if we fail to point
out the most trivial of instances and
it's only going to make it more
difficult to hold these folks
accountable for the more egregious
rights violations this is hell I'm hell
my clients are healthy my family's
healthy there's a my children over there
if you see them they all have excellent
health and normal weight you know we
don't have to go to dentist we don't go
to the doctors very often it it did me a
lot of good when I Rocky Mountain
spotted fever it's what helped me get
back to the to be able to walk and
function properly what do you hope to
accomplish with this event today there's
a couple things we hope to accomplish
first and foremost I think what we want
to do is let let what we're doing
resonate to other people and help them
be brave to stand up and exercise their
rights as well I think we're just going
to shed more light on on our liberties
as free people and the right that we the
right that we have that we have to
freely exchange goods and services I
think it's exercising your rights but I
also think it's getting the word out
that yes we might not be free anymore
this event proves that you know what we
did last year was effective we're just
going to keep doing this to you know
once we gain that freedom ground we
don't want to lose it again so we'll
keep doing this year after year until
we're never having a problem with police
harassing people over voluntary exchange
some say she's a libertarian hero or a
Dairy Dairy Queen
but see this I don't really like milk
that much but that's pretty good maybe
it's just time out I don't know past
your eyes on the scene
it's a member shire movements outside
from the LA